I was just outside no shoes on smoking
smoking a blunt with a pink headband on
and like a a bright pink hoodie and a
young dude and a young guy standing next
to uh an older gentleman who just pulled
up how did you just describe me older
gentlemen what the [__] can you hear me
do you need me to yell it older
gentleman listen dude first of all I'm
gonna let you finish the story but don't
you ever describe me as an older
children I didn't say elderly man I said
older [__] mine call me an older
gentleman 53 is an older gentleman
older gentleman what do you want me to
say
I don't know
exactly like so there what they're
seeing is an older gentleman like I'm
not trying to bag like Michael Kane dude
I'm just saying if I was driving by and
I saw the two of us I would think young
man older gentleman I'm not Sir Paul
McCartney he's older gentlemen Paul
McCartney is an elderly man okay okay
but also it looks like an elderly
lesbian but that's he does dude that's
what I'm saying like I'm not again not
bagging just observing he does kind of
look like him elderly yeah yeah anywho
yeah but I was thinking I was like yo
what I wonder what these people think
and he goes what do you mean I go what
do they think of what they see right now
in front of them is me in shorts I was
in no shoes just socks okay I was
smoking a blunt with a pink headband on
it actually and a pink hoodie on what I
said first was you were like I wonder
what they think and I was like I said to
you but they just see a father and son
and you're like they don't know where
Father and Son exactly you'll see some
older gentleman in his gray sweatpants
and tank top smoking weeds smoking weed
with his joint next to a younger dude in
no shoes a pink headband and a pink
hoodie also smoking weed standing
outside of his car 100 with somebody
drove by and was like they're [__]
yeah oh
that's what I'm saying like if I join
what is what would be your thought like
I'm gonna clip this and put it down in
the comments what would your thought be
if that was the picture that that's
usual Vibe like